l'aventuré lui trotte s'est arrêté au
mois de juillet 2020 la start-up
yvelinoise a été contrainte de déposer
le bilan
engagé dans la location de trottinettes
we trust a lancé en 2019 la production
des premières stations destinées au
quartier de la défense
un investissement de 300 mille euros
problème la société ne réussit pas à
trouver d'investisseurs
nous avions un bilan même s'il était
négatif en termes de trésorerie à fin
décembre on avait encore des fonds
propres qui était assez conséquente
euros de fonds propres
on avait trouvé des marchés on avait
notamment à l'opérateur de transport
public qu'ils étaient prêts à nous
accompagner nous aider dans la
plantation des stations sur certaines
villes plus un groupe hôtelier plus deux
sociétés dans le monde du bâtiment
donc on avait les on avait des
ouvertures qui est intéressante les des
négociations en cours
en mars 2020 ces négociations en cours
aurait permis de trouver des solutions
aux problèmes d'investissement
le colis de 19 est venu casser cette
dynamique en entraînant ensuite la fin
de l'entreprise louis trotte on a fait
les demandes auprès des organismes
d'état donc pour obtenir un prêt garanti
par l'état puisque nos banques ont
refusé de les bandes venues suspectes là
ont refusé le pge nous accompagnons on y
avait encore le président lilian ce
n'était pas suffisant pour pouvoir tenir
le coup on devait absolument aller
chercher à peu près 200 250 mille euros
pour pouvoir relancer l'activité
garder les salariés cette société née à
saint quentin en yvelines en 2010 est
fondée par christophe bass et grégory
hanquez et pascal chanvin sur la suite
du projet et de l'idée laventure
pourrait se relancer mais le temps est à
la réflexion autour de la solution de 8
roth